les beaux jours semblent maintenant de
retour aéroports de montréal a connu une
hausse de plus de 4 100 % du nombre de
passagers au 1er trimestre 2009 1,2 par
rapport à la même période en 2021 avec
nous ce soir pour en parler philippe
rainville qui est pdg d'aéroports de
montréal monsois monsieur rainville le
pire est certainement pas c est ce qu on
est même revenue au niveau d'avant
pandémie 1 en 2019 était vraiment une
année record pour leur part de montréal
avec 20 millions de passagers mais je
vous dirais qu'on a vu des chiffres tout
près de 70%
des chiffres qu'on avait vu en 2019 pour
le mois de mars par exemple on était on
est à 55 % mais le secteur international
va lui est tout près de 70% donc c'est
vraiment nationale c'est les touristes
qui viennent ici et ceux qui s'en vont
oui et fournit 70% des pour le mois de
mars portant à l'international et à peu
près 50 6% pour le total on s'attendait
pas à faire plus que 50 % cette année
c'est vrai que c'est un retour très
rapide oui si vous donc prêt à faire
face à l'heure où oui on était prêts je
vous attends tu es prêt pour le mois de
juin on s'attendait à une grosse vague
la main une grosse vague d'arrivées en
juin mais de voir que déjà à pâques
c'était s'était déjà aussi plein c'était
on était surpris ou est-ce que qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour vous parce que ça
a été deux années très difficiles mais
vous êtes restés ouverts bien sûr vous
deviez même rester au 20 secondes pointe
et donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
reprendre les activités vous vous
rappelez des gens qui est qui d'accord
du m à qui je présume ah oui on ne met
plus que tout ce que 25% de nos gens nos
effectifs qui étaient retournés à la
maison mais l'engagement et on avait
quand même une petite vague de reprise
juste avant noël vous souviendrez donc
on avait commencé à ramener les gens et
on les a conservées qu'on les a gardés
donc on était relativement après
pourquoi pas cette année et comme je le
disais on se prépare et surtout pour
rejoindre a plaidé jean ramener tout ce
monde-là au travail et vous savez
pénurie mais deux voiliers chef on est
comme tous les secteurs de ramener tous
ces gens-là l'aéroport c'est difficile
mais on y arrive on y arrive on sera
prêt pour l'été soit six heures pour
ouvriers est ce que le voyage d'affaires
a repris ou six ans on est encore très
très heureux est ce pour ça que quand on
fait nos prévisions il a toujours 25 %
de trafic qu on doute qu'ils reviennent
rapidement et c'est justement ce comme
vous le dites si bien ce sont les
voyageurs le faire quand est-ce qu'ils
vont revenir à livre faire des
rencontres de clients aller à toronto 1
c'est un vrai marché pour nous aller
vers l'europe et ça on est encore un
sens si vous êtes à peu près à 50 60 70
% de ce que vous aviez avant la pandémie
vous vous attendez à revenir à 100 et
même à plus que 100 % à quel moment mais
selon ce qu'on attend ou ce qu'on lisse
et 2024 ouais je vous irez avec ce
constat en ce moment je crois que ce
sera probablement plus rapide on va
parler 2023 le voyage d'affaires sera
peut-être pas là mais dans la
littérature on est content assez de
revenge travelling les gens contre le
maire de partir aussi incroyable donc je
crois que peut-être que on est une
grande poussée sataniques et
relativement peut-être l'an prochain
dans le voyage touristique et
l'inflation ça vous touche mais si votre
chien pour l'instant savoie le prix des
billets a pas été trop affectée c'est le
prix du pétrole ça c'est évidemment
c'est une composante importante du prix
du billet mais jusqu'à d'apt tous
maintient une légère augmentation mais
c'est pas ça n'empêche pas les gens du
voyage mais une crème de récession qu'on
évoque pour pour faire peur aux gens la
mêlée les économistes en parle si on
augmente fortement les taux d'intérêt
pour tenter de calmer l'inflation il ça
viendra l'an tire davantage l'économie
vous serez de nouveau affecté ce dont
nous sommes absolument corrélé au pib
donc ralentissement économique un autre
secteur habituel absolument vaut suivre
mais cette économie ces économies que
les gens engagés y sommes qu'ils ont
l'air est dédié vers le voyage il faut
voir va falloir voir passer c'est
peut-être cette phase là avant de tomber
paternalisme mais on constate ici par
contre on a parlé beaucoup des problèmes
dans les chaînes d'approvisionnement les
ports qui était engorgé il ya eu du
déplacement quand même moins de
transport vers l'est les avions les
aéroports est ce que vous en avez
profité chez aéroports de mont louis
basset migrer vers lens et demi avec une
hausse du fret d'un peuple à 10
personnes l'an dernier mais faut quand
même comprendre que ce qui est dans les
appareils c'est quand même matériel
léger et les problèmes de logistique
c'est dans des gros containers donc tout
ce qui était musical et venues par avion
un beau coup beaucoup de mal à masquer
en extérieur les vaccins et mais on est
quand même une belle rouste à mirabel de
10% les masques parlons-en aux états
unis sur les vols intérieurs les masques
ne sont plus obligatoires depuis une
semaine au delà est-ce que ce qu'on
devrait aller au canada également j'ai
senti public décidera avec transports
canada je crois que ça va être
progressif au canada on est légèrement
plus rude a donc
est-ce que ça viendra améliorer vos
affaires s'il n'y avait plus de masquer
ce qu est un irritant ou un frein pour
prendre l'avion non c'était vraiment les
tests 1 quand on a vu que les tests
étaient plus obligatoire pour revenir au
canada c'est là qu'on a vu le pousser
dans dans la demande non je crois pas
que le fait le match qu un irritant
majeur dernier point vous avez dû revoir
l'échéancier de la station durée est
reliant le centre ville qui sera pas en
service à la fin de 2024 n'est ce pas
comme prévu on en est où dans ce dossier
là on commence à creuser on vient de
donner le contrat on est en train
d'ajuster justement nos échéanciers on
va voir une heure on va avoir une bonne
idée à l'automne du nouvel échéancier
quand on se sera arrimé avec celle du
pup perdant ses difficultés et va donc
on sera cet automne mais c'est sûr que
c'est interdit on a perdu 1 mondial
ouais ouais avec sa part fait libreville
merci d'avoir été reçus très intéressant
merci bien pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]